our subject
finders keepers matthew 24
reading verse 11 matthew 24
reading from verse 11. i am the true
vine
and my father is the husband man
every branch in me that beareth not
fruit
he taketh away and every branch that
bear
fruit he purges it that it may bring
forth more fruit
now you clean through the word which i
have spoken unto you
abide in me and i in you
as the branch cannot bear fruit of
itself
except it abide in the vine no more can
ye
except he abide in me i am the vine
hear the branches he that abideth in me
and i in him the same bringeth forth
much fruit
for without me you can do nothing
if a man abide not in me he is cast
forth as a branch
and is withered and men gather them and
cast them into the fire and they are
burned
if he abide in me and my words
abide in you ye shall ask what ye will
and it shall be done unto you i am
grateful to god again for this
glorious privilege of speaking for him
somewhere i read in the writings of
ellen white i don't recall where
angels occasionally ask god to allow
them to speak and talk about jesus
and that privilege is denied to them but
given to sinners such as i
people made of flesh and dirt and dust
and clay
and so i'm very conscious that what i am
doing is a privilege
angels would love to exercise and the
least
i can do to express my gratitude to god
is to give you thus saith the lord
and that and no more thank you very much
for joining in
i'm always delighted to welcome anyone
listening who is not
a seventh-day adventist wherever you are
if you're watching
may the lord speak very directly and
personally to your life
and may he bless you in every area of
your life
and put a hedge of protection around
your family
and if anyone listening has contracted
the coronavirus
the prayer of my heart is that god
who tells us in exodus 15 26
i am the law that healeth thee i my
prayer is that god
will remove that affliction from you
completely
and restore you to health and that
because of this goodness of his in your
life
you may feel that holy urge to commit
your life to him
as a way of saying thanks for his
blessing on your life
i thank god for freedom of worship which
we still
enjoy in this country and many other
parts of the world
but as several of the adventists we know
that this
freedom will not last forever it will
soon be lost
and we will be functioning and living
under very very difficult
conditions indeed and that loss will
begin
right in these united states that
is known for freedom of worship and
freedom
of religion our subject for tonight or
today
is finders keepers
finders keepers as always i ask you
wherever you are
please preserve reverence in your
environment
because of the covet 19 virus we are
worshiping
zoom and other platforms youtube and
facebook and
this way and it's easy to listen without
a
sense of reverence because we're not
sitting in a church
but god is god regardless of
environmental conditions
god is always holy and as you listen to
the proclamation
of the holy word please feel the earth
the desire the need
the mark of respect to preserve
reverence where you are
five number two while i'm speaking pray
for me and say lord put your words
in that man's mouth jeremiah 1 verse 9
then the lord put forth his hand and
touched my mouth
and the lord said unto me behold i have
put my words
in thy mouth and favor number three
think as you listen think
jeremiah 12 5 says if thou has
run with the foot man and they have
weary
they how cans then thou contend
with the horses if you cannot keep pace
with a man
how do you plan to keep peace with a
horse god calls upon us
to reason which means that honest common
sense is part of the christian walk with
god
use your common sense reason reason for
instance
several verses in the bible tell us
clearly the seventh day is the sabbath
not one verse tells us the first day is
the sabbath yet many people observe the
first
now if someone will reason honestly that
person
must conclude that a sabbath is the
seventh day
based on biblical information because
not one
verse in the bible declares the first
day to be holy
and so god says come now let us reason
together
saith the lord isaiah 1 18.
our subject finders keepers
let's bow our heads and pray
loving father in heaven thank you so
much for the joy
the honor of speaking for you i do not
deserve this privilege father
and i consider myself unfit and so i ask
you in the name of jesus
who understands what it means to be
human who felt the weakness
and who leaned on you for strength by
constant prayer
help me regard possess my mind i want to
be holy spirit possessed a god
let the spirit use me as he sees fit
father i offer no resistance if i've
offended you
forgive me the god calvary allows you to
forgive
bless those who listening bless these
children a very special way if they're
listening
and remember our non-adventist guests
who may have tuned in
touch their lives father and if anyone
listening to god
has contracted the coronavirus i ask you
in the name of jesus that name that said
let there be light the same name that
said on the cross it is finished
the same name that said i am the
resurrection and the life
in the name of jesus god
heal any listener who may have
contracted the coronavirus
restore that person to health now father
i commit this message to your glory
first
and may it bring a blessing to those
listening
i offer this prayer from my heart in
jesus name and for his sake
amen our subject
finders keepers matthew
24 reading verse 11
matthew 24 reading from verse 11
and there shall arise or many false
prophets shall arise and shall deceive
many
and because iniquity shall abound the
love of many shall wax cold
verse 13 but he that shall endure
unto the end the same
shall be saved
listen again to matthew 24 4 13 but he
that shall endure unto the end
the same shall be saved shall
is a future tense which means that there
is an
aspect of salvation that is reserved
for the future when someone comes to
christ
and honestly and sincerely recognizes
as his or her only hope in that moment
the person surrenders
and accepts the sacrifice of jesus
christ
as sufficient that person is justified
and that person is saved
that's present salvation now the bible
says
he that endureth unto the end
there is one thing or such a thing as
immediate salvation
there is something called walking in
that saved state
when the publican went into the temple
to pray luke 18
he said in verse 13 god be merciful to
me a sinner
in verse 14 jesus says i tell you this
man went down to his house justified his
words were god
be merciful to me a sinner someone
crying for mercy
is someone in a helpless condition and
he looks to someone in an
advantageous position to act graciously
towards him
the man realized he was a sinner and he
needed help
outside of himself and so he said god
be merciful to me a sinner and jesus
said
he went down to his house justified
or made right with god now
that man must then have continued
in that state growing and growing in
grace
there is such a thing as instant
salvation but the bible says
he that endureth unto the end
the same shall be saved
demas was once a disciple of god he
worked with paul
paul says demas hath forsaken me having
loved this present world he left he did
not
continue until the end in his high
priestly prayer
john 17 jesus said those that thou give
us me i have kept and none of them is
lost
but the son of perdition referring of
course
to judas iscariot who did not endure
unto the end he that endureth
unto the end the same shall be saved our
subject is
finders keepers let us go to genesis
chapter one
we look at creation and see what lessons
we can learn
regarding salvation as we get into this
message
finders keepers i'll pray again father
in heaven
do not relax your control of my mind
let me just be an instrument and you
have all the say
in jesus name i pray amen matthew 1 not
matthew 1 sorry
genesis 1 reading from verse 1.
i read from the king james version of
the bible
this is my favorite verse in the bible
by the way genesis 1 1
and in the beginning god created
the heaven and the earth in the
beginning
god created the heaven and the earth ten
little words
that contain an encyclopedia of
significance
in the beginning god created the heaven
and the earth first too
and the earth was without form and void
and darkness was upon the face of the
deep
and the spirit of god moved upon the
face of the waters
and god said let there be light and
there was light
and god saw the light that it was good
and god
divided the light from the darkness and
god called the light day
and the darkness he called night and the
evening
and the morning were the first day
the creator was jesus christ acting
on behalf of the father and the father
himself
informs us in hebrews chapter 1 verse 10
the father says speaking to the son and
thou
lord in the beginning has laid the
foundation of the earth
and the heavens at the work of thy hands
that's what the father said
john 1 reading from verse 1 in the
beginning was the word
and the word was with god and the word
was god
the same was in the beginning with god
all
things were made by him and without him
was not anything made that was made
jesus christ
is the creator acting as the agent of
the father
it is also very correct to say the
father is the creator
but he accomplished that through jesus
christ his agent
i hope there's no confusion there christ
is also the agent
of salvation because god was in christ
reconciling the world unto himself and
so
jesus created the question becomes how
did jesus do that
verse 3 and god said
let there be light and there was light
creation
was accomplished by the word of god this
is something i've
preached on many many times and i
suspect as long as i live
i will talk about creation and the fact
that it was accomplished by the word of
god
because there is a spiritual parallel
if any man be in christ he is a new
creation
david prayed create in me a new heart of
god
and renew alright spirit within me
conversion
is a work of creation
let me show you how
when christ created he created as the
scholars say
ex nihilo out of nothing hebrews 11
3 through faith we understand that the
worlds were framed
by the word of god so the things which
are seen
were not made of things which do appear
out of nothing
god created matter out of nothing god
created angels
the bible says in psalm 148 verse 5 he
commanded
and they were created angels were just
created out of nothing
god spoke and they showed up the word of
god
is powerful beyond our imagination
we have physical creation by
the word of god listen to hebrews
chapter one
let's read from verse one hebrews one
reading from verse one our subject
finders keepers
hebrews one verse one or from verse one
god who at sundry times and in diverse
manners
spake in time past unto the fathers by
the prophets
hath in these last days spoken unto us
by his son
whom he hath appointed heir of all
things by
whom also he made the worlds who being
the brightness
of his glory and the express image of
his person
and upholding all things by
the word of his power stop
the bible tells us the creator who
created
by the word upholds creation
by that same word now there's a verse
that is
even more explicit in expressing that
truth
second peter chapter three we'll read
verse five
then skip to seven our subject finders
keepers second peter three reading from
verse five
for this they willingly are ignorant of
that by the word of god
the heavens were of old and the earth
standing out of the water and in the
water listen to the verse again
for this they willingly are ignorant of
that by the word of god the heavens were
of old and the earth standing out of the
water
and in the water now verse 7 but the
heavens and the earth which are now
by that same word are kept in store
the word that created is the word that
maintains
that's a biblical truth now we can also
read
what we read hebrews chapter one verse
three and we just read second peter
three
five and seven the creation is
maintained
by the word of god and creation was
accomplished
by the word of god
what does that have to do with salvation
and finders keepers
god creates and expects what he creates
to remain
let me say it again when god created
heaven and earth he expected them to
remain
forever because sin was not in god's
plan and destruction
and deterioration and anarchy all are
the results of sin
god's original plan was that his
creation
would remain but sin entered
because of sin we read these words in
hebrews 1
let's read from 10 to 12. our subject
finders keepers
hebrews 1 reading from verse 10 let me
pray father
please continue to tell me precisely
what to say and grant me the humility to
say it and to suppress my carnal nature
in jesus name i pray amen hebrews 1
verse 10 and thou lord in the beginning
has laid the foundation of the earth and
the heavens at the work of thy hands
listen to verse 11
they shall perish thou reminisce
does paul say they shall perish because
of sin
sin contaminated the earth and sin began
in heaven
thou remainest they shall perish they
all
shall wax all as the the garment and as
a vestige shalt thou fold them up
and they shall be changed but thou are
the same and thy years shall not
fail in other words paul is contrasting
the eternity of god
with the temporary nature of creation
contaminated by sin
this sinful world this sinful heaven
will come to an end
that's why john tells us in john 21 not
john revelation 21 1
and i saw a new heaven and a new earth
because of sin the original earth and
the original heaven
will be destroyed ii peter chapter 3
reading from verse 10
to 12. but god's design is
that his creation would continue
and i need to stress the word continue
of the word
remain of the word abide
we know from first peter chapter 1 verse
the bible says being born again not of
corruptable seed
but of incorruptible by the word of god
which liveth and abideth forever
let's read that verse again first peter
1 23
our subject finders keepers
being born again that's justification by
faith
that's conversion that's a new birth
being born again not of corruptible seed
but of incorruptible by the word of god
which liveth and abideth forever
in other words conversion is brought
about by
the word of god received into the heart
of the sinner
signs of the times april 30 1896
paragraph two conversion is accomplished
by the reception of the word in the
heart
the new birth is accomplished by the
reception of the word
in the heart creation
was accomplished by the word conversion
is accomplished by the word james
chapter 1
verse 18 james was the half-brother of
jesus he said
of his own will beget he us with
the word of truth conversion is brought
about
by the reception of the spirit-filled
word of god
conversion is a form of creation
now i told you earlier that scholars use
the expression
ex nihilo to refer to god creating
out of nothing it functions the same way
at the level of salvation we have
physical creation
ex nihilo we have spiritual creation ex
nihilo
let the bible inform us on this point
listen to jesus
in john 3 reading verse 6. john is my
second favorite book my number one book
is genesis
john 3 6 listen to jesus
that which is born of the flesh
is flesh and that which is born of the
spirit
is spirit simple language a child can
understand
but profound
the spirit is all spirit
and the flesh is all flesh
flesh and blood shall not inherit the
kingdom of god
meaning the carnal nature not the
physical we'll have physical bodies in
heaven
flesh and blood the carnal nature shall
not inherit the kingdom of god
jesus said that which is born of the
flesh
is flesh that which is born of the
spirit
is spirit meaning there is no flesh
in the spirit and there is no spirit in
the flesh now
let's go to john chapter 6 verse 63
jesus speaking again
it is the spirit that quickeneth the
flesh
profiteth nothing
paul was inspired many wrote in romans 7
i know that in me that is in my flesh
dwelleth no good thing
he was inspired but jesus himself said
the flesh profiteth nothing now
jesus says in john 3 6 the flesh is all
flesh and the bible says flesh and blood
cannot inherit the kingdom of god
jesus said in john 6 63 the flesh
profiteth
nothing paul says in romans 7 18 i know
that in me that is in my flesh dwelleth
no good thing now here is the situation
the sinner there is
nothing in the sinner that commends him
to god other than his need
the great need of the sinner but the
sinner himself
his constitution his makeup his mind
there is
nothing in the sinner that can be
offered to god
as raw materials with which to bring
about the creation of
on a spiritual level nothing and so god
really
has to create out of nothing spiritually
as he creates out of nothing physically
but as the physical creation
was designed to remain
the spiritual creation is designed
to remain
salvation is not a flesh in the pan
experience you come to christ
that's instant justification now you've
got to walk
in that way you've found him you've got
to keep him
what's your subject finders
keepers too many people presume to find
christ
but will not keep him they believe one
save always save i found him
i have a place in heaven now let me live
the life i desire to live
that's not the way salvation functions
jesus christ
must be kept faith and works
page 100 paragraph 1 god requires the
entire surrender of the heart
in order for justification to take place
and in order for man to retain
justification
there must be continual obedience
control living faith
there must be continual obedience in
order for man
to retain justification no wonder jesus
himself said
in matthew 24 13 he that endureth
unto the end the same shall be saved
let's go to the reading i offered at the
beginning of the presentation
john 15. john
15. if you've never read the book of
john carefully please
read it before reading it look at verses
30 and
31 of chapter 20 of the book of john
the last two verses of john 20 he
explains
why he wrote the book when you
understand why john wrote john
you will want to read john and digest
john and make john your spiritual food
he tells you
why he wrote that book the last two
verses
of john chapter 20 but for our purpose
we are in john
chapter 15 reading from verse 1 and i
ask my heavenly father again
to continue to speak through me and give
me no sense of myself as i represent him
in the name of jesus amen
i am the true vine and my father
is the husband man every branch in me
that beareth not fruit he taketh away
and every branch that bears fruit he
purges it
that it may bring forth more fruit in
other words continue to
be fruitful verse 3 of john 15
now you clean through the word which i
have spoken let me digress
a little bit in a good way
the word of god has a cleansing effect
on the mind
and this is very consistent with what
the previous speaker said that people
can have victory of all kinds of
weaknesses
the word of god has a cleansing
purifying effect on the mind jesus told
the disciples
john 15 3 now ye are clean
through the word which i have spoken
unto you
verse 4 abide in me
the greek word meno means to stay to
remain abide in me
and i in you as the branch cannot bear
fruit of itself
except it abide in the vine no more can
ye
except ye abide in me i am the vine hear
the branches
he that abideth in me and i in him
the same bringeth forth much fruit for
without me
he can do nothing if you read from john
about john john chapter 15 1 to 16 the
word abide occurs about
16 times most times it is translated
abide
it's also translated remain or continue
continue in my love i think that's verse
verse 10 says if you keep my
commandments you shall abide in verse 16
ye have not chosen me but i have chosen
you and ordained you that ye should go
and bring for fruit
and that your fruit should remain same
greek word for abide in me
same greek word for continue in my love
jesus
is stressing the absolute importance
of staying in a saved condition
you found me keep me
you know someone said we have found the
messiah
many people find jesus that's good
keep him stay with him
because he has said those who will be
saved are those who
endure to the end your end may be
tonight god forbid
well we all say god forbid but if that's
the only way god can save you maybe i
shouldn't say god forbid
you know god saves some people i put him
in the grave that's the only way he can
save them he puts them
in the grave god saves some people by
humbling them through sickness
or economic disaster god finds all kinds
of ways to save
because god is more concerned with
saving your soul than your economic
situation
but what i'm saying is this we must
endure remain
verse 6 of john 15 as we continue
finders keepers if a man abide
not in me if he does not remain if he
does not stay
if he does not endure he is cast forth
as a branch and his withered
who does the casting forth listen to
verse 2 of the same chapter
every branch in me that beareth not
fruit
he taketh away who is he the husband man
in verse 1
that's the father
let me say it again slowly
the father has his role to play in
salvation the son has his
the holy spirit has his the angels have
their rules
jesus says i am the vine
my father is the husband man
every branch in me that beareth not
fruit he taketh away
some people leave the church and they
blame other people
if you're truly connected to christ
no one can break that connection but you
let me say differently when satan when
lucifer was made by god he was the most
powerful angel in heaven
when he was thrown out he took all his
power with him
so he's the most powerful entity
outside of god and divinity and the
trinity
satan with all his power cannot make you
leave jesus
and god with all his power cannot force
you to stay in jesus
and so jesus says every branch in me
that beareth not fruit
he taketh away and every branch that
buried through
he purges it that it may bring forth
more fruit
and then we have abide abide abide we
were in for six
if a man abide not in me
he is cast forth as a branch and is
withered
and made gather them and cast them into
the fire and they are burned
verse 7. if he abide in me
and my words abide in you he shall ask
what ye will
and it shall be done unto you this verse
is heavily abused by those who believe
that god is an atm machine
you just stick a card in get what you
want god is just a
a pinata you hit it and something falls
out
listen to verse 7 of john 15 then we
shall go back to verse 4 and to verse 5.
john 15 7 says if ye abide
in me and my words abide in you
we have two things my words abide in you
and i abide in you
keep this in mind let us go back to
verse four
now concentrate
listen to verse 4 abide in me
and i in you
i hope you're thinking abide in me
that's you and me i in you so the sinner
in god
or the saved person and god in the
person abide in me
i in you as a branch cannot bear fruit
of itself
except it abide in the vine no more can
he accept you abide in me so we have
abide in me i knew in john 15 verse 4
abide in me i knew let's go to verse 5.
i am the fine here the branches he that
abideth in me
and i in him and so we have again abide
in me
and i in you i hope you see that but in
verse 7
jesus says if he abide in me and we saw
it in four and we saw that in five
and my words abiding you are
instead of i abide in you now jesus says
my word abiding you meaning
that christ abides in us
through the word take some time to
compare john 15
4 john 15 5 with john 15 7
and it's very clear that when jesus says
in john 15 7
if he abide in me and my words the words
there represent
jesus christ himself christ abides in
us through the word
the spirit-filled word when the word
abides
in a person
here's what the effect is verse three
now
you clean through the word
which i have spoken unto you with the
word of god
abiding through active living obedient
faith
it purifies the mind it cleanses the
intellect
so that we begin to pray in a manner
consistent with the will of god
the word instructs us as to how we ought
to pray
because paul tells us in romans 8 26 we
know not how we ought to pray
the word of god dwelling in us instructs
us in how to pray and so jesus says if
he abide in me
and my word in other words if you stay
in me
and my word stays in you you will know
what to pray for and it shall be done
abide in me we must remain
in jesus christ now let's go back
to verse 4 of john 15.
i hope someone listening to me has
already prayed and said lord
put your words in that man's mouth when
i make that request
it is a concentratedly serious request
because when people pray for you god
listens because that prayer is according
to his will
that his words would be put in my mouth
listen now john 15
4 abide in me and i in you
as the branch cannot bear fruit of
itself except it abide in the vine
no more can ye except you abide in me
now if you apply your mind to that verse
what you learn is dynamite
jesus is the vine of the main trunk
you and i are the branches
follow me closely whatever
flows through christ
flows through the branches
let me say it again i'll say differently
i'll come backwards branches are
sustained
by the main trunk you cut off a branch
the main trunk remains
you cut off another branch the main
trunk remains because the trunk
is attached to the root
what is it that sustains christ i'm not
sure sustain is the right word but i'll
use it
divine power
that is what flows through the divine
the trunk divine
power now when a branch is grafted on
what gives life to that branch divine
power
again this goes with the previous
presentation divine power is enough
to grant you and me victory over any sin
and any weakness
you've heard my words i'm not sure you
understood what i'm saying
what is made available to the branch is
divine power
now you tell me here is divine power
here is smoking you tell me which has
more power
the question is do i believe that here
is
divine power here is
selfishness which one has more power
abide in me and i in you as the branch
cannot bear fruit of itself except it
abide in the vine
no more can ye except you abide in me
the life of christ
becomes the life of the believer now
statements like these are almost
difficult to conceive of
or to accept because they sound so
impossible but my listening friend
as verily as divinity and humanity
blended in jesus christ
he was human and he was god you and i
can be human and godly
not god godly we are required to be
human and god-like
and that element of god likeness is the
very life of christ
in us let me say it again that
god-likeness
is the result of the life of christ in
us
but it is a growing experience
and so we grow in grace and in the
knowledge of our lord and savior jesus
christ
because the knowledge of christ john 17
3 is salvation
by knowledge we mean you know you accept
you respond you obey
the power in the branch is
the very life of jesus christ
but jesus says abide stay
in the vine remain stay there
hang in for the long haul you found me
now keep me he
that endureth unto the end the same
shall be saved we think of the end we
think of many many years ahead no
just stay faithful to christ today
now within the next hour
as you accomplish that victory
faithfulness today
it becomes easier to be faithful
tomorrow so when the bible says he that
endureth
unto the end don't think of 50 years
ahead you may not see it you are alive
today
jesus said in luke 16 10 he that is
faithful in that which is least
is faithful also in much now you just
have today
that is least be faithful today if god
gives you tomorrow
be faithful tomorrow and as you do that
you find you're becoming
faithful in much because you've been
faithful
in the least our subject
finders keepers listen to christ
expressing the same concept in chapter 6
of the book of john
let's go to john chapter 6 we'll read
from verse
51 john 6 51 we're trying to establish
the point
that coming to christ is one thing
remaining in christ is something else
creation had to be maintained that was
god's original plan
sin brought in a problem but god will
remake heaven
remake earth and according to isaiah 66
they shall remain because there will be
no more sin can salvation
conversion is creation then we must
remain
and as the physical world is maintained
by the word
the spiritual creation is also
maintained
by the word we're in john chapter 6
reading from verse 51
our subject finders keepers
and those of you listening at home i
hope you're writing down these verses
so you can refer to them later to be
sure i am speaking from the word of god
like the bereans
they double checked the apostle paul if
paul can be double checked what about
this little
insignificant preacher john 6 reading
from verse 51 father in heaven
continue to give me clarity of speech i
pray in jesus name
amen i am the living bread which came
down from heaven
if any man eat of this bread he shall
live forever
and the bread which i will give is my
life which i will give for the life of
the world is my flesh
which i will give for the life of the
world now bread
means that which sustains
bread and water will be sure meaning
food that which sustains
is symbolized by bread and water
jesus says i am the living bread
which came down from heaven i am that
which sustains you
if any man eat of this bread question
how often do we eat to be sustained
every day several times a day and jesus
knows he made us we require sustenance
and food
and nutrition we eat several times a day
some two some three
some all during the day grazing as they
call it and jesus says
i am bread
if any man eat of this bread meaning
sustains himself by this bread
he shall live forever and the bread
which i will give
is my flesh which i will give for the
life of the world
jesus now in john 15 tells us attach
yourself to the vine
and what nourishes the vine will nourish
the branch divine power
jesus says i am bread you consume me
and when you consume me i will nourish
you from within
spiritually and the symbolism in john
chapter 6 for me
is even more powerful than john 15.
it's the same concept which is to unite
with christ and to remain in christ
when you eat bread or whatever you eat
it's broken down in the stomach and the
nutrients
all that's valuable and necessary for
maintaining life gets
to the very cells of the body
you see something in your stomach is not
yet in your body i hope you understand
what i'm trying to say i'll say it again
i'm not a doctor
but something in your stomach can be
regurgitated
something in your cells cannot be
i said that clumsily let me say it again
there are people who can just make
themselves vomit
they stick their fingers down their
throat and out comes
veggie meat and soy milk whatever else
people eat
you cannot do that when the nutrients
have gotten to your cells you cannot
vomit what's in your cell so jesus says
eat this bread meaning you eat it you
digest it it gets to your cells
where it will remain nourish you
spiritually
i am the living bread which came down
from heaven if any man eat of this bread
not just chew
you eat your swallow it's degested he
shall live forever and the bread which i
will give is my flesh
which i will give for the life of the
world the jews therefore strove among
themselves saying
how can this man give us his flesh to
eat what did jesus say to them
verily verily i say unto you except ye
eat the flesh of the son of man
and drink his blood ye have no life
pause
life can be said to be an instant yes
but life is generally viewed
as a sustained experience
life christ says
except you eat the flesh of the son of
man
and drink his blood ye have no life
now when you understand he's referring
to the word verse 63 the words that i
speak unto you
they are spirit and they are life you
understand that jesus christ is saying
your life is this
it is this that allows you to endure
unto the end it is this spirit-filled
word
that brings to us the very life of jesus
christ
by the word in verse
54 of john 6 he that eateth my flesh
and drinketh my blood dwelleth in me and
i will raise him up at the last day for
my flesh is meat indeed
and my blood is drink indeed who so
eateth my flesh and drinketh my blood
dwelleth in me and i in him verse 57 as
the living father have sent me
and i live by the father so he that
eateth me
is so he shall live by me now jesus says
the same way
i live by the father whoever eats me
lives by me
stop what does he mean
let me slow down listen carefully
jesus tells the disciples eat my flesh
and drink my blood
that's how you live then he said
if you eat my flesh and drink my blood
you will live
the same way i live by the father what
does he mean
i eat the father's flesh and drink his
blood meaning
i eat the father's word i live by the
father's word and he's simply saying
the same way i live by my father's word
i want you to live by my word and so he
says
in verse 57 as the living father have
sent me
and i live by the father
so he that eateth me even he shall live
by me
how do we remain we remain in jesus
by constant faithful obedience
to the word of god by listening friend
we're in a time in this world's history
when we will have to put our trust in
the word of god
because events around us will test our
faith
and the only thing we will have to hold
on to will be god's word
when christ was on the cross before he
gave up the ghost
hello white tells us he saw no way out
of the tomb
his last words were into thy hand
i command my spirit christ died
trusting the father let me say it again
jesus christ died trusting the father
and so he said
into thy hand i commend my spirit
at a critical moment of his life
we are approaching a time when
conditions will be so trying
and so horrible the only thing that will
sustain us
is a faith in god's word that resembles
recklessness
and the way i always refer to it is
simply this
you may have seen it on one of my
sermons you see this bible
it's black the color's black but if the
word of god says this is white
even though you see black you must say
white you didn't hear me let me say it
again
this bible visually is black
but if the word of god says this is
white
we must say white even though we see
black
this is living by faith in the word of
god
jesus said after three days i will rise
now
someone knowing that a guard had been
put at the tomb
the tomb had been sealed powerful roman
soldiers were standing around
how could they believe that christ could
come from that grave
but the word said after three days i
will rise again to believe that might
have looked like
folly of the highest or lowest degree
but jesus came back
because the word said that
and christ was tempted in the wilderness
he told the devil something that applies
to all of us
man shall not live by bread alone
but by every word when jesus said man
he included himself he was a man he
still is a man
he included himself jesus lived by
every word that proceeded from the
father by the way
when he said every word he was referring
to the ten commandments
he was referring to the ten commandments
haven't got time to go through that and
show you when jesus said
man shall not live by bread alone but by
every word
he was referring to the ten commandments
if you study the responses of christ
to the three temptations of the devil
each response came from a section of
deuteronomy
that only deals with the ten
commandments chapters five through
eleven
all three responses of christ came from
deuteronomy 8 and deuteronomy 6
the section that dealt with the 10
commandments when jesus says
man shall not live by bread alone but by
every word
he was referring to the ten commandments
because the ten commandments according
to solomon
are the whole duty of man
my listening friend our subject finders
keepers have you found jesus
keep him have you been converted
walk that life you've experienced
justification
walk that way there's a reason why
there's justification
and there's sanctification and i
frequently say the first step in
sanctification
is justification there's no gap between
the two
you found him stay with him
and so matthew 24 13 tells us he
that shall endure until the end
the same shall be saved
and i ask you in the name of this same
jesus who loves you
and desires to have you in his kingdom
walk with christ persist with him
trials will come because the
faith must be tested if jesus was tried
if jesus was tested surely you and i
must be tried and must be tested but if
we obey
the word of god through the indwelling
power of the spirit of christ
the obedience of faith there is no trial
there is no test there is no tribulation
that the enemy can bring against you
that can overthrow you
because the enemy understands that what
rebuffed him in the wilderness
when he tempted christ is what will
rebuff him today
it is written
you shall know the truth and the truth
shall make you free
let me say it briefly and respectfully
error
however sincerely followed sanctifies
no one you shall know the truth the jew
shall make you free
sanctify them through thy truth thy word
is truth no one is set free by error
there are some people in the slavery of
error but they are happy
in that slavery not knowing the
condition that they need to be awakened
to the
perilous condition in which they're
living
there's a the vampire backed
before it bites when it bites his victim
it it it ex
it it it gives off some sort of
substance that
keeps the wound flowing and almost
anesthetizes the
the the animal from which is drawing
blood and the animal is giving up blood
not even knowing that his blood is being
sucked up
many people in error are quite fine
because they do not rely
the perilous condition therein but only
truth can set a person free only truth
can
sanctify and we know from first
thessalonians 4
3 and this is the will of god even your
sanctification
and jesus said accomplish that through
the word
thy word is truth tonight i offer you
the truth
that those who come to christ must
remain in christ
as ye have received lord so walk in him
we receive him by faith we walk by
faithful obedience
we receive him we walk in him we're
converted we continue that life
let me give you that quotation again
faith and works page 100 paragraph one
god requires the entire surrender of the
heart
before justification can take place and
in order for man to retain justification
there must be continual obedience to
active living faith continual obedience
through the power of christ that allows
the sinner saved by grace
to walk in that justified state
my appeal to you tonight
review your relationship with christ
look at the past six months in your life
look at the past six months
look at it on a whole and ask yourself
this question
i said look at the past six months are
they taking me this way
or that way life is never this way
there's no flat lining spiritually
you're either going this way
or you're going that way as you review
the past six months
of your life have you been going this
way or that way
if your honest assessment is this way
stop now
recommit your life to god grip his hand
again
and start all over with christ
upward and forward second peter 3 18 but
grow
in grace and in the knowledge of our
lord and savior
jesus christ let's pray father in heaven
thank you for your word it is powerful
it is disturbing it cuts
it divides families because some accept
some don't
but always they god it is truth
always father if received it saves
if i have said anything i should not
have said forgive me
and i pray that those who listen their
god will reflect on what they heard
and they will allow the word of life
that created the universe
the word that converts they will allow
that word to sustain them
the word that cleanses the word that
energizes
the word that fortifies us against satan
if they have found christ
let them keeping through active living
faith the obedience of faith
hear this humble prayer father when you
come may you find that we through your
power
have endured unto the end i offer this
prayer with thanksgiving
in jesus name amen
you